The Joe Rogan experience.
What essentially was hacking Dharma?
Like what was the motivation behind it?
Was it for a person like
me or was it for everyone?
Like as far as for everyone.
And so what I really wanted to do,
so the background's going to be gift.
I can give you just a
little bit of background.
So more than 20 years ago I was working
on the National Security Council and my
then boss, um, Richard Clark,
who was then this obscure White House
official who is jumping up and down saying
we need to be focusing on terrorism
and al Qaeda and bin Laden.
And he was trying to tell everybody
and nobody was paying attention to is
totally marginalized.
And when nine 11 happened,
I'm Dick's memo was on George Bush's
desk saying exactly that we need to focus
on [inaudible].
Here's what's going to happen to,
and Dick even before then would always
tell me that if everyone in Washington
was focusing on one thing,
you could be sure there was something
much more important that was being missed.
And so more than 20 years ago,
I was looking around and I saw these
little pieces of disparate information and
I came to the conclusion that the
genetics revolution was going to change
everything. So I educated myself.
Um, I started writing articles.
I was invited to testify before Congress
and then to try to get that story out.
I was, I started, I wrote my, my two
most recent, um, near term Scifi novels,
Genesis Code and Eternal Sonata.
And when I was on book tours for
those and I explained the science, uh,
to people the way I kind of a self
educated citizen scientist, um,
and a novelist would explain the science,
all of a sudden people got it.
And that was when I realized I needed
to write a book about the genetics
revolution that people could
absorb that wouldn't scare people.
But my mission for the book is that
this stuff, as we've talked about,
it's so important that everybody
needs to be part of the conversation.
We have this brief window and what I'm
calling for is this species wide dialogue
on the future of human genetic
and genetic engineering.
And I have a whole game plan, uh, in
the book about what people can do,
how they can get involved,
a people individually on a national level.
We have to put a lot of pressure
on our elected leaders and say,
stop focusing on the crap.
There is really important stuff that
needs to be addressed and we need
leadership. I'm going to, I'm speaking
on, uh, in, uh, in Congress, um,
and we can a half from now
talking about about these issues.
So we need to have an them
on an international level.
We have to have some kind
of international system.
We're so far away from
being able to do that.
We don't even know what the standards are,
but we have to be pushing it.
So I know you think of it in terms of
like the same way we have with nuclear
weapons. Yeah. In a way.
And in many ways. Yeah.
But the thing is with nuclear weapons,
a lot of that happened at the state level,
at the country level. This needs to
happen at a popular level and at a, uh,
at a government level.
So the only way that those that's going
to happen effectively as we need, um,
real comprehensive
education on the subject.
It's not something that
people can just guess. Right.
And need to know what's the consequences,
what where we're at right now. Yeah.
Right. Yeah. And that's, and
that's like Sanjay Gupta, um,
had a wonderful quote that's
actually on the cover of my book,
which is if you can read one book on
the future of our species, this is it.
So what I've tried to do is to say like,
if you just want to go to one place
to understand what's happening,
what's at stake,
what it means for you and what you can
do now if you want to get involved.
I've tried to do that, but then
ironically I'm now like, as I mentioned,
being asked to speak to thousands of
doctors and scientists because they're all
reading this book and they're saying
this is, this is positioning my work in,
in a much bigger content.
Sanjay Gupta is a very interesting cat
because he was very anti marijuana and
then started doing research on it and
then totally flipped 180 degrees. Yeah.
Which to me is a great sign of
both humility and intelligence.
I recognize that the data was different
than his presuppositions. Yeah.
He had these prejudices that were
very common. Yeah. Yeah. Now,
when you speak to Congress,
yeah. What do you,
do they brief you in terms of like what
they would like specifically for you to
address?
No.
So this one, um, it's, uh,
I've been asked to go and speak into a
lot of members of congress who were going
to be invited. And what I'm
going to tell them is, look,
this is really important.
Our congress is not doing enough and
here are the things that we need to do.
And what are you going to say to try
to really get it into their head?
What I'm going to say is that
the genetics revolution is here.
If we don't have a system,
if you don't have a rational system to
manage it, if we don't have a system.
You talked about public education.
The challenge that we face in the United
States is we traditionally have had a
representative democracy and now we're
transitioning from a representative
democracy to a popular democracy.
So Switzerland has a popular democracy,
but they have like really well
educated people who are able,
who have enough information
to make smart decisions.
We haven't educated our public and yet
the public is making big decisions and a
lot of it is happening
just on a gut feeling.
That's what's happening with trade
agreements where people just have,
I have a feeling it's bad
without the ability to, to,
to really get into the, into the details.
And so we are having that transition,
which means there's a lot
of responsibility on us
to educate our public.
And it's just, it's a tragedy.
We treat people in this country.
Like you can just throw
people away like you somebody,
if you're in some crappy school
system and you know your, your,
your chances of success are so minimized,
not because of anything that you've
done just because of your circumstances.
And it's unacceptable.
It is only, sorry. I mean
the equal opportunities,
what we really should all strive for us,
and I think some people
conflate that with, uh,
op equal success.
Right?
And you're not going to get
the same equality of outcome.
You're going to get different,
different amounts of effort and different
people are qualified or more talented
at different things. But what I'm
worried about is what I said initially,
that some people are going to get a hold
of this stuff quickly and it's going to
give them an a massive advantage.
Yes. Sort of like, I mean,
if you, the first person that has
the ability to go forward in time,
five minutes,
right. Is going to be able to
manipulate the stock market and yeah.
Unprecedented way.
Yeah.
I don't think that that's
really possible in our lifetime,
but that's the kind of
thing I'm talking about.
You could get so far ahead that if
we're talking about competition,
that will be no catching up.
They'd be,
you don't have to travel
in time to do that. Right.
But I'm saying that if it was,
but there's real technologies
that are likely to happen,
which are going to confer billions,
tens,
hundreds of billions of dollars
of benefit of advantage. Yeah.
And that stuff is happening now.
And this is the concern with
getting behind countries like China,
cause if they get ahead of us and
something like that when they were already
moving in this direction in
terms of technology. Yeah.
So I am a proud American. My father
and grandparents came here as refugees.
I believe in what this country
at our best dance floor.
I want us to continue to be the country
that setting an example for the rest of
the world that is articulating what our
ideals of responsibility and governance,
good governance and accountability and
all these things that we have championed.
And because of that, I want us to
get our act together politically.
And I want us to be the leading
technological country in the world.
Um, and so I think that's what's what's
at stake and we're losing so much time
because there was a time in the period
after the Second World War where we
recognize that technological leadership
was the foundation for everything else
we were, we had recreated the world
out of the ashes of the, of the war.
But we realized that we needed
to have the economic growth.
We needed to have the competition,
we needed to have these technologies,
and we've, it was a miracle.
What we've, what we've done,
and now we've lost our focus
and we have to regain it.